um you know
if you want to talk about bill gates
like the first thing he did before that
even happened before the internet even
got big is i believe it was dell was
trying to sell pcs with linux
pre-installed instead of windows wow so
linux would have would have had like a
decent market share and gotten a lot
more momentum than it got as a desktop
operating system what bill gates did is
he basically um
he did some sort of deal i don't know
the details precisely but it was
something about like
unless you're exclusive microsoft
windows on your pcs that you're shipping
you're gonna pay a lot more
per
license so dell would pay like you know
five bucks a license or something for
windows and it would have been 10 bucks
or something if they had als if they
kept selling linux machines so so
linux is awesome
i uh for those that aren't familiar it's
it's open source free operating system
that works really really well i guess
because it's uh linux it most people
would recognize it because it's similar
to mac os right
um
yeah mac os was derived from a unix
it was derived more from freebsd which
is unix hard to tell the difference
really but so you know for all of you
out there who use mac you might easily
understand what uh what linux is
i think a lot of uh big chain stores use
linux for their terminals for like
self-checkout and stuff because it's
free and they have to pay licenses but
it's really amazing i didn't know that
story that bill gates basically shut
that down because
imagine if we did not have
microsoft windows as the dominant
platform imagine if it was a free open
source technology
and you get some
jerk like bill gates who comes in and
sticks his foot you know in the door and
then stops that from happening so he can
control that piece and now you have tech
oligarchs like him specifically and now
he's gone from just being some guy who's
like i think you should have my
operating system instead too there's too
many people on this planet and we should
have less people
right and all that went i know tim you
bring up antitrust enforcement because
that has played sort of a good a role as
a final check here over the decades it
took 10 years of practices like that
before finally it was the the internet
explorer integration that finally did
trigger that
we've seen far less you know antitrust
has not provided an effective check in
the last bit here on what i think most
observers would say is at least somewhat
anti-competitive practices among app
stores and 100 other things we could go
into
i think that the fact is we need
something like fudo because
antitrust is not going to to handle it
on its own uh there are there are things
that inherent in the system as it exists
now that are anti-competitive that make
it i mean down to the engineers
themselves that the sort of um
the model of silicon valley now is to
lock up talented engineers within four
or five or six companies forever
not based particularly on their output
but based on the fact that them being
there prevents viable alternatives from
coming into existence
now steve jobs i hear he was kind of a
dick as well was that the case
i mean
sure yeah i mean
i would say like one quality that like
you know all these oligarchs um
the trait that they have in common
they're they're all kind of me
steve jobs is maybe special but like if
you look at like someone like mark
zuckerberg they're mediocre
above average programmers right maybe
they're you know top 10 programmers what
the trait they really have is they do
like to control things
so like bill gates
was having a connection when linux when
dell was trying to sell linux computers
mark zuckerberg was having a conniption
when he saw that you know tons of people
were uploading photos to whatsapp
instead of facebook like which you know
within a couple years that happened um
wow
so yeah so steve jobs is the same thing
like very very very very controlling
people
like steve jobs is like
you must have one i don't know if you
remember he insisted on one mouse button
for a long time even though there were
so many people who wanted like two mouse
buttons well there was the gag i think
it was the onion who made it where the
new mac was just instead of a keyboard
it was a it was a wheel
and if you wanted to try it you had to
wheel to the letter and then press the
button because it's just simpler that
way right i i couldn't i could i
couldn't stand apple it's the same thing
it's like these these these people want
to
control and extract as much as they can
from from everybody now look good
business good for them i suppose but i
remember my friends telling me that they
were they were obligated by their
professors to buy mac to use it for
school or whatever and i'm like that's
five times more expensive for the same
processing power they take it was it
freebsd you said take a unix system they
slap their logo on and then charge you
money for it
i mean they do i'll give them a bit of a
pass they did a lot of good work and
honestly you know in 2006 2007
they were still very small market share
like they actually did beat microsoft by
making it better so i'll give steve jobs
a pass you know if you're the small guy
and you're you know trying to control
things
that's okay
if you're like if you have your vision
your unified vision for a beautiful
product and you're at 10 market share go
at it as soon as you get to you know
have too much power like 50 market share
and the only other player is also 50
you know that's when you gotta like step
you know step it back a bit for sure i
suppose it's fair to say steve jobs
never came out and said there's too many
people so we got to figure out how to
reduce those numbers
and population growth because that's
kind of a weird thing for a for a
computer guy to say oh buying farms and
stuff yeah yeah
it kind of makes me think like
when you have a big
uh network you kind of want to see what
the people want and then build the
network to support that as opposed to
build a network that decides what the
people are going to want but that
there's so many people that want so many
different things it becomes challenging
if not impossible to to support all
those different ideas at once that might
be what's stopping them from why they
become so authoritarian and controlling
the network
but i haven't been in that position yet
so i'm not sure exactly what's causing
it
to to rise to the position where you are
running a company like microsoft you
have to genuinely believe you're smarter
and better than everybody so it's like
if you if you take a hundred people and
you you put them in a sieve and you
shake it as hard as you can to see what
falls out and what sticks the people who
hold on the tightest you know they're
the ones who are have that have that
energy so naturally the person who rises
to the top at big massive companies like
this are the people who are like i'm
smarter i'm better everyone's got to do
what i say
that's why you end up with the bill
gates yeah and the collusion works i
mean the closing works you're going to
win if you're colluding somebody who
just wants to you know likes competition
and wants if they see a threat and they
say well let's do better like let's view
this as a friendly competition that
person's going to lose to the colluders
so it's you know it's kind of formed
naturally this monopoly in a lot of ways
and i want to add one more thing to what
i was just saying uh there i was reading
about how celebrities tend to be
sociopaths they tend to be narcissists
and egotistical er very arrogant
and it's it's actually fairly simple as
to why that is
you have two people
one person is very humble one person is
narcissistic which one's going to get up
on stage and shout out how beautiful and
amazing they are it's gonna be the
narcissist the humble person's gonna be
like well you know maybe it's not for me
you're gonna have someone say i'd like
to audition for this role and they're
gonna say we don't know if you haven't
they're gonna go well okay you know i'll
try harder next time you get the
arrogant narcissistic guy and he's gonna
be like no no you're wrong i am the best
and i'm going to prove it to you and
they're like this guy's got energy
those people are going to rise to the
top and that's one of the challenges we
face i suppose with a free market is
that snake oil salesmen
con artists arrogant narcissists are the
ones who end up gaining tons and tons of
power and rarely do you find someone who
uh
doesn't have those qualities but just
does a really good job or i should say
not rarely but less often
i mean
yeah they they get bored or they they
they feel like they've accomplished
something and they just want to go live
their life they don't really care about
controlling things and and they've done
their thing
there are a lot of people
many people i follow on twitter for
instance and yeah they they they do
really well and they're like well you
know i did my thing and i don't want to
be the boss i want to be in charge and
they dip out it's like the the killer
instinct probably is what they call it
it comes from our past hunting like if
you were if you didn't have that killer
instinct and you couldn't hunt properly
then you would die and you didn't but
the ones that could hunt and kill and
then kill the their opponents so that
their village didn't get raided and
murdered
then they survived so now there's this
killer instinct in business which is
like maybe we're doing it wrong
that's why i'm doing free software
anyway i think it's i think i think it's
wrong i don't understand locking down
that
all the money it doesn't make sense i
always go back to culture is is is the
most important if if we if if as a
culture people were into open source and
linux and stuff bill gates would lose
all his power and he'd be like the
wicked witch of the west melting like
people adopting linux across the board
would be incredible for that reason we
got to explain it you said graphene os
so you get an android phone you you
flash graphene os onto it which
basically means you erase the operating
system and reinstall a new one um which
is an open source software called
graphing os right right it's uh this guy
daniel mckay is doing graphene os and
there's a few other
groups doing similar things with the
android open source project um
so
one these things we have to understand
we need to make these things better
before we're going to get tens of
millions of people using them which is
what i you know i want there to be i
want to be hundreds of millions of
people using
software that is not locked down by the
oligopoly
how do you do it how do you uh flash a
new software operating system on your
phone
um it's i just did it it was uh not easy
i i bought the phone they told me to buy
it turned out that it was locked down at
some point in the history of the uh
phone because it was refurbished so i
had to get another phone
um
you know you go through you can go
through the the instructions at the
graphene os site it's pretty pretty
pretty straightforward like
your grandmother could probably do it or
your mother-in-law could probably do it
if she has the right phone like
and it's still gonna not work as well as
you want though it's worth it i love it
i i most of the phones i've had
throughout my life except for except for
iphone i can't stand iphone what i would
always put on some either bare bones
android operating system just gut all of
the bloat and the garbage that they put
into it and then just get that base
system or using something you know like
graphene there's been a whole bunch
throughout the history of android that
are just better simpler cleaner safer et
cetera what are some problems with it
you were saying that sometimes it
doesn't work as good what's the problem
with it yeah i mean that's that's the
problem i mean you have problems with
like uber working with your
phones tim
was that like does uber work well with
your phone like a lot of these so some
of you okay yeah so some of these some
of these apps that people expect to work
won't work especially no anything very
notification heavy you know those rely
on google's uh services to work
well right so is that a monopoly
google's notification system
uh it's not quite a monopoly but it's
one of these things that as we like to
say this google software is much more
delightful both for the user and the
developer um so there's a long way to
come in that a big that's not a slide
against graphene or any of these other
groups they're doing fantastic work i
i've been using windows since 93 or 92
windows 3.1 and uh it's because of video
games i use steam and i couldn't game on
linux for like late 90s early 2000s i
mean valve is doing a lot of great work
trying to make linux work well for games
and i i think that like i'm a gamer like
like i
started out doing games for yahoo
so i love what valve's doing to try to
make linux better for games but it just
is kind of hammer home how difficult
this problem is that
valve is this super
super powerful i consider them to be
like one of the better
companies that's kind of on the more
independent side of things with steam
being so popular
they have not been able to
deliver a successful linux product yet
they're trying now the steam deck
hopefully that works thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm we'll see you all there